[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'édition
publique une semaine après la
présidentielle manifestement emmanuel
macron prend le temps de choisir sans
frais au ministre et son gouvernement
sans doute en saura-t-on la semaine
prochaine la gauche elle se dépêche de
faire l'union autour du plus puissant de
leurs représentants désormais contenu la
présidentielle si jean luc mélenchon bon
soit vu un bail aux bons soins alors
merci d'être avec nous bien venu
d'ailleurs vous avez une nuit courte une
journée chargée vous revenez à peine
d'une séance de négociation froid que
vous allez retourner une fois qu'on aura
fini les messieurs vous en est où là
exactement et bien en fait après vous
aviez parlé de la présidentielle après
la présidentielle on a entendu le signal
séparément les gauche les écologistes ne
pourront pas pesé dans le quinquennat
qui vient disons le comme ça ça leur
attendez on va reprendre tout mais là
précisément dans la négociation nous on
a tiré les conséquences de sa haie
séparément nous sommes condamnés à
l'impuissance ensemble additionnées en
organisant cette coalition on peut et
c'est ça mon l'enjeu allait chercher une
majorité à l'assemblée les 12 et 19 juin
vous pouvez l'appeler troisième tour de
la présidentielle vous pouvez l'appeler
occasion historique
d'organiser un programme qui agit enfin
pour le climat pour les réductions
drastiques des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre pour le développement des
énergies renouvelables pour la
rénovation thermique pour le
rétablissement des services publics pour
l'augmentation des salaires voilà ce que
nous mettons dans l'accord voilà ce qui
est en jeu le 12 juin et douala on se
donne les moyens et hier après de
longues discussions mais en vérité des
longues discussions en quelques jours
nous avons décidé avec la france un
smith de créer ensemble une coalition
une bannière commune la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale sur la
base d'un projet extrêmement ambitieux
pourrait développer parce qu' on parle
de ça vous êtes parti là cet après midi
bonne nouvelle c'est que les socialistes
ont dit nous souhaitons discuter alors
discussions veut pas dire accord mais on
est en train de dire alors julien maio
vous êtes une secrétaire nationale des
verts hier soir vous êtes sorti sur le
perron avec manuellement par la france
soumise à dire qu'on a un accord ce que
vous faites maintenant c'est d'agréger
les autres partis de gauche à cet accord
et la suite ont en tout cas on est là
c'est ce que vous souhaitez mais vous
vous avez votre accord vous ne direz
tout à l'heure si tiens ils ne sont pas
là si vous me permettez sinon le type un
petit mot ces conditions c'est mieux
comme témoin s'est d'abord excusé moi je
le sais pas voilà donc ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que notre émission on va
s'organiser cette façon là on va essayer
de comprendre sur quelles bases vous
avez compromis vous avez signé cet
accord comme enjeu qui était d'abord
simon comment ce qui était impossible
hier les par miracle aujourd'hui
pourquoi et comment êtes d'accord
éventuellement pour vous asseoir sur des
désaccords quels sont vos objectifs tous
talents brigitte boucher steve jourdain
iront dans le fond justement sur le fond
de la question vincent où vous posons
une question d'actualité dans un quart
d'heure et il très art est un droit vous
parlez d'un du contexte plus général de
ces discussions je sens que vous êtes
encore une fois où tu as quel vous êtes
à fond si vous a fait une union
aujourd'hui
c'est parce que dans le fond revenons la
jeunesse vous avez échoué à porter haut
les couleurs de l'écologie et la
présidentielle vous en tirer les
conséquences les gens tirent toutes les
conséquences mon rôle en tant que chef
de ce parti c'est d'être lucide nous
avons échoué nous avions un potentiel
électoral le climat est très haut dans
les préoccupations des françaises et des
français et pourtant nous avons échoué
dans cette campagne c'est un échec
collectif quand on finit à moins de 5%
c'est aussi un problème financier je
vais pas vous le cacher nous avons une
ardoise de plus de 5 millions d'euros et
c'est pour ça que nous avons
immédiatement lancé un appel à soutien
sur un soutenir l'écologie point fr je
suis très heureux qu'on est déjà dépassé
plus de deux millions d'euros on a une
date limite pour obtenir 3 millions
d'euros il nous reste 1 millions d'euros
d'ici le 15 mai mais c'est un échec et
donc on doit évidemment en tirer les
leçons pour plus tard et moi j'organise
ce bilan collectif
quelle stratégie
comment mieux porter notre projet
pourquoi au moment où la crise en
ukraine la guerre en ukraine arrive et
que tout le monde comprend enfin que
l'europe est si importante pourquoi nous
nous qui le portons ce projet européen
et même de défense européenne depuis si
longtemps on n'a pas été en résonance
avec l'opinion pourquoi quand le prix du
gaz augmente que tout le monde se dit
tiens on est pris à la gorge par les
factures et que nous nous disions depuis
tant d'années la rénovation thermique
l'autonomie énergétique et la réduction
de la dépendance la voiture c'est aussi
un moyen pour le porte-monnaie d'être
indépendant vis-à-vis de tous ces chocs
qui vont se multiplier on n'a pas réussi
voilà disons 2 et donc on doit en tirer
le bilan je ne n'ai ce qui ferait rien
simplement il ya aussi un enjeu immédiat
c'est les législatives et donc tirer les
leçons cette stratégie ça veut dire
aussi ce qui n'était pas possible à la
présidentielle parce que c'est la
présidentielle c'est une bonne amie une
seule femme qui qui qui conduit et bien
c'est plus simple aux législatives où il
est possible d'organiser une coalition
plurielle qui respecte les cultures les
identités et qu'ils aillent chercher
l'addition des électorats la présidence
va encore plus loin on va aller plus
loin parce que effectivement à cause du
mode de scrutin majoritaire pour
législatives qui est une chape de plomb
quand même pour un parti qui fait moins
de 5% pour avoir renoncé lors avoir des
élus aussi plus de 5% ceni est aussi
plutôt avoir des nuls enseignait aux
municipales où nous gouvernons à lyon à
strasbourg mais ce que vous réussissez
précisément minimale vous on ne peut pas
y arriver dans un scrutin majoritaire au
législatif sauf si on s'unit donc pour
avoir des élus à l'assemblée eh bien
vous décidez c'est pragmatique de faire
cette union c'est la seule façon d'avoir
un groupe mais s'est laissé plus que ça
nous ne souhaitons pas juste avoir un
groupe bien sûr qu'il faut un groupe on
a vu ces latrines numériquement
je suis précisément en train de vous
répondre
nous ne souhaitons pas seulement un
groupe bien sûr que nous voulons un
groupe de députés alors pas le
développer mais sur la chaîne
parlementaire on comprend l'importance
des groupes d'un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale nous avons vu dans le mandat
précédent qu'un groupe écologiste
manquait que quand la convention
citoyenne pour le climat est passé à la
broyeuse par le président de la
république malgré toutes ses promesses
il a manqué un groupe écologiste pour
ferrailler infléchir proposé construire
ces propositions si si nécessaire pour
le climat donc évidemment que nous
voulons un groupe mais nous voulons
aller plus loin nous ne voulons pas
perdre 50 plus pour le climat ou subir
la casse sociale que premiers pas être
absents nous voulons une majorité voilà
ce que nous voulons faire nous voulons
envoyer des bataillons de députés
écologistes bien sûr insoumis
socialistes communistes de gauche à
l'assemblée c'est ça que nous voulons
organiser une majorité est possible
absolue relative ça dépend avec 165
circonscriptions gagnables mais on est
sur 550 combien gagne
non non c'est ça ça n'a rien à voir nous
parlons d'un accord global sur
l'ensemble des circonscriptions cette
coalition
c'est un accord global l'enjeu c'est
bien de là si leur candidature au
meilleur endroit qu'est ce que ça change
au fait que vous pourrez pas avoir une
majorité à l'assemblée est ce que vous
pensez une seule seconde vous pose la
question de façon extrêmement j'allais
dire benoîte que jean luc mélenchon et
la coalition puisse avoir une majorité
qui puisse aller à matignon c'est que
vous pensez je vous avoue que évidemment
il ya trois semaines je vous aurais dit
non
aujourd'hui tout est ouvert nous avons
un président de la république qui nous
disait c'est urgent de faire ceci cela
qui n'a pas apparemment trouvé de
premier ministre apparemment il ya rien
d'urgent voilà ce qui était absolument
urgent dans l'entre-deux tours et
l'écologie devait être le parangon à
nouveau comme il l'avait déjà fait dans
le passé bon ben en fait
en fait il s'en moque
là le président actuellement est en
train de regarder un parent un bon jour
la séparation des pouvoirs de regarder
un par un les candidats aux législatives
du mouvement en marche pas c'est lui qui
regarde tout seul voilà ce qui fait
aujourd'hui
t
il le fait tout seul il le fait tout
seul vous avez une possibilité de
division à l'extrême droite j'ai entendu
le déchirement des frères ennemis de
l'extrême droite vous avez l'extrême
droite qui est divisée vous avez les
droites qui sont divisés lr horizons en
marche nous sommes en train d'organiser
possiblement une coalition qui peut
effectivement renverser le cours des
choses dans ces deux écuries loin faire
alors quand on croit avoir une majorité
vaut mieux s'entendre sur des questions
fondamentales et notamment des
orientations aussi importante que
ce qui concerne le rapport à l'europe on
va dire un mot parce que l'europe voilà
ce que dit l'accord sauf erreur il faut
que je retrouve voilà pour être en
capacité d'appliquer notre programme
respecter le mandat que nous aurons
donné les françaises et les français il
nous faudra dépasser ses blocages les
blocages et être prêt à désobéir à
certaines règles européennes en
particulier économiques budgétaires
comme le pacte de stabilité et de
croissance le droit la concurrence les
orientations productiviste et néolibéral
de la politique agricole commune etc
n'en jetez plus dans le respect de la
loi ils sont jamais ça c'est l'europe à
la carte non non vous écoutez je vais
vous répondre mais si vous terminez de
lire la phrase dans le respect de l'état
de droit sans jamais sortir de l'europe
de l'euro ni agité la désagrégation de
l'europe quel moment on fait les le fond
du sujet c'est bien tu viens
pas l'europe c'est ce que je fais madame
c'est ce que je fais madame un mois j'ai
écrit tout un livre qui s'appelle
désobéissons pour sauver l'europe parce
que je considère et nous considérons
notamment que le cadre austérité absolue
la limite à 3% nous empêcher de mener
des investissements dans la transition
écologique j'ai écrit ce livre en 2018
2019 et je disais c'est 3% nous empêche
de développer les énergies renouvelables
de développer la rénovation thermique
nous l'aurions fait ce sont des
centaines de milliers de ménages qui
serait dans une situation plus favorable
aujourd'hui voilà ce que nous avons raté
à cause de ce carcan l'austérité et le
fait de privatiser les services publics
toutes ces règles elles ont volé en
éclats c'est la pandémie et la france
n'a jamais été sanctionné pour avoir
dépassé les règles budgétaires et voilà
ça c'est une règle pour appliquer ce
programme pour appliquer ce programme il
nous fera effectivement si nous voulons
construire du logement social que c'est
un investissement rentable l'emploi
était d'accord pour pendant la crise
sanitaire que effectivement tous les
pays déroge à la règle il ya eu un
accord des 27 si tous les pays font
comme vous prévoyez de le faire c'est à
dire
des désobéir est prêt d obéir à
certaines règles européennes mais si
chaque pays se fait sur l'annoncé plus
on dit est-ce que ça n'est pas faux pose
la question est-ce que ça n'est pas une
europe à la carte bien sûr que non bien
sûr que non le portugal l'a fait
l'allemagne faire un point oui sera
point il ya toutes ces règles j'ai dit
le droit la concurrence des orientations
ou sommes-nous là vous vous savez
peut-être que nous sommes nombreux
membres écologistes de gouvernements en
europe a souhaité non pas la sortie de
l'europe europe ecologie les verts je
pense qu'on peut pas faire plus clair
nous sommes écologistes nous sommes donc
considéré comme un des pays les plus
europhiles vous associer à un martyr ils
considéraient comme un robe est ce que
nous sommes prêts européens oui est-ce
que nous sommes satisfaits du
fonctionnement actuel de l'union
européenne non personnes dont l'une est
pâle et la politique agricole commune
l'est la polémique des cas 27a de la
politique agricole commune nous avons
voté contre non pas parce que nous n'en
voulons pas mais parce que nous n'avons
pas pu peser suffisamment pour la
réorienter l'autriche qui a un
gouvernement avec une coalition
écologistes à une pac verte une
politique agricole commune verte c'est
donc possible et donc il s'agit de mener
cette bataille au niveau requins non pas
pour en sortir mais pour la ré orienter
désormais en allemagne vous avez une
coalition dans lequel c'est pas rien
vous avez deux super ministre anna lena
barbeuk ministre des affaires étrangères
robert avec ministre de l'économie il
marque voilà ce que ça les verts
allemands travailler avec le luxembourg
avec la finlande avec l'irlande dans
lesquelles il a besoin des gouvernements
et que le char est assez fou en fait ce
rapport à l'europe que ce nouveau
rapport à l'europe que vous avez compris
avec la france à je continue la france
insoumise elle dit on va déroger aux
règles s'ils sont intelligents
nous allons déroger aux règles sur un
certain nombre de points en attendant de
modifier les traités c'est ce que
effectivement ils ont intégré la
nécessité de modifier quoi que les
traités continent c'est une négociation
pour modifier les sinon ces discussions
passionnantes j'ai expliqué que et vous
l'avez dit ce cadre osterrieth r il n'a
jamais été respectée en vrai je crois
qu'il ya eu 160 5
infractions pour non respect des 3%
celle de maastricht où les 60% ça c'est
l'endettement nous savons ce à tous a
été mis entre parenthèses vous l'avez
dit du fait de la pandémie
la question est on à un moment
historique faut-il un retour au statu
quo et bien nous disons non au contraire
l'europe peut être un formidable outil
d'investissement dans la transition
écologique c'est ce retard que nous
n'avons pas faire et impactent
d'ailleurs écologistes à green deal qui
a été conclu et est européens écoutez si
vous mettez le gaz dans les énergies
vertes on ne sort pas vous comprenez
bien qu'aujourd'hui on s'en mord les
doigts en tout cas j'espère à la fin des
années 90 je vous irez à la fin des
années 90 ya eu un tourment tournant
vous me dites que c'est l'europe moi je
peux pas l'expédier en 30 secondes gens
nous sommes passionnés
et donc je termine pas leur termine dans
mots à la fin des années 90 il y avait
une majorité à l'époque avec 15
gouvernements en europe y avait une
majorité de gouvernements sociaux
démocrates ils ont raté le virage
c'était la proposition de la réduction
du temps de travail du salaire minimum
et des grands travaux 1 la rénovation
thermique notamment pour développer le
potentiel et améliorer la paix la
prospérité en europe ils ont fait les
critères de maastricht le traité
d'amsterdam c'est bien donc possible de
réorienter c'est une question de volonté
politique voilà ce que nous voulons
faire enfin modifier la coalition s'y
engage et j'appelle toutes les forces
pro-européennes à venir batailler avec
nous pour réorienter le cours de
l'europe en ont le merveilleux que nous
avons devant nous ne pas au contraire
retour au statu quo mais quelque part
les esprits ont bougé même à la banque
centrale on parle désormais des
relations de la dette vous rendez compte
ce qu'ils étaient et ce qu'ils étaient
il ya quelques jours aurait dit des
choses comme andy sauf que vous me dit
pas comment j'en tire les conséquences
il ya ceux qui parlent et nous nous
voulons agir pour réorienter le cours de
l'europe et nous avons des généraux pour
ce faire en allemagne en irlande au
bénin revenir sur le fond de l'accord
avec ctv et brigitte je pourrais pas
pendant j'ai bien compris j'ai deux
questions précises dans cet accord cet
accord est ce qu'il est destiné à
gouverner ensemble oui s'il n'y a pas de
majorité qu'est ce qu'il devient eh bien
on continue à travailler ça nous fait un
mandat quand nous disons par exemple est
ce que pareil placera les émissions gaz
et par exemple à l'assemblée nationale
puisque vous espérez avoir un groupe
vous aurez un groupe 1 la france est
soumise à un groupe les autres
partenaires éventuels aurons un groupe
est ce que il y aura une consigne de
vote est-ce que vous voterez sous une
bannière commune je vais pas vous
apprendre que le tout mandat impératif
est nul c'est écrit dans la constitution
un député est une députée c'est tout
l'honneur de cette fonction doit pouvoir
voter en sa liberté pour des consignes
de vote par l'enjeu pour nous c'est un
intergroupe c'est pouvoir structurer
cette coalition dans le respect de la
culture de chacun chacune nous nous
sommes écologistes nous prenons mandat -
60 % moins 65 % de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre voilà
l'enjeu donc ça veut dire que vous à
l'elysée des députés écologistes membres
de cette coalition vous savez que
pendant cinq ans il ya pas de majorité
nous iront batailler pour encore réduire
ses effets pour le climat place à
delphine batho est d'accord ils sont en
train de voter on a dit qu'elle est
d'accord on est partout
on est membre du pôle écologiste on a
tenu informés dans les discussions on a
négocié pied à pied ses aspects qui sont
pour nous fondamentale notamment sur sur
l'europe le mouvement génération
écologie est en train de se prononcer
donc moi je le respecte comme je
n'aimerais pas qu'on se prononce sur les
votes au sein d'europe écologie les
verts je crois que le vote est en cours
il se termine demain et on pourra en
discuter dans la suite mais
évidemment que cette coalition se donne
pour objectif de peser et de ne pas
subir un quinquennat d'inaction
climatique et donc je conçois que par
exemple cédric vidal ans cédric villani
m'a dit que pour lui c'était évidemment
essentiel cédric denis parent qui est
membre de génération
verra on verra ce qu'il en est c'est
intéressant parce que delphine batho
site une ancienne ministre de françois
hollande qui a porté l'environnement sur
les questions européennes ce sera
intéressant de voir si elle s'aligne pas
sur la corde on va on va tout de suite
rejoindre vincent roux du figaro live en
même temps qu'on va accueillir moi j'ai
bouché steve jourdain mots chargés mon
cher vincent bonsoir à vous et je vous
laisse poser votre question à un julien
bayou bonsoir julien bayou une polémique
monte en ce moment
revient plus exactement elle porte sur
l'autorisation du burkini dans les
piscines et en particulier à grenoble
vous le le met où le maire donc eric
piolle que vous connaissez bien donc
soulevé la question au conseil municipal
donc d'une division une division en
particulier à gauche est ce que vous
vous soutenez eric piolle sur cette
question ou bien vous pensez comme
d'autres élus de gauche qui ont fait une
pétition que ce n'est pas un simple
maillot que c'est une tenue que c'est
plus qu'une cabinda et qu'il s'agit et
mais que c'est pas ça ne s'est pas
simplement une tenue de bain en tout cas
ce que disent ces élites gauche et qu'il
s'agit d'une décision grave à laquelle
il faut s'opposer
alors c'est étonnant parce que je crois
que suis venu quelques fois dans cette
émission et je crois que
systématiquement on m'a parlé des
maillots de de grenoble et jamais et des
maillots à rennes jamais et vous savez
que les ses maillots dont vous parlez ne
sont pas autorisés à grenoble vous venez
de dire ils sont autorisés à rennes
alors ça c'est incroyable parce qu'on ne
parle que de grenoble et jamais de
rennes alors qu'à grenoble ça n'est pas
d'autoriser ces trente années déjà
laissez-moi vous peut-être me répondre
on me parle des maillots à grenoble ça
n'est pas autorisée
et jamais des maillots à rennes où c'est
autorisé alors mettons quoi depuis 2
3ans accessoires - ce qu'on pouvait
répondre à ça que sur moi je la
programmation la position d' eric piolle
me semble la bonne ni injonction ni
discrimination et il réclame si c'est un
sujet si fondamental moi je pense que
les maillots c'est pas le plus important
mais enfin bon je réponds il dit ni
injonction des discriminations à partir
de là faut-il une règle nationale où est
ce qu'on s'en remet au règlement
intérieur des piscines comme dans chaque
commune comme c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle lui il a dit bah écoutez si
c'est si important au premier ministre
et aux présidents qui s'occupe de tout
de déterminer la règle il a demandé ça
est alors en attend on attend nous
attendons une position nationale de la
part du premier ministre si c'est un
sujet si important si ces mineurs et moi
j'ai envie de vous dire les maillots de
bain c'est une chance sur six sur un
cépage un conseil municipal ça ne relève
pas et bien votre féminisme n'étions pas
un tout petit peu chatouillé par la
question du pire que du burkini ni
injonction ni discrimination c'est
d'ailleurs la position du défenseur des
droits on en a malheureusement je crois
déjà parlé parce que c'est quand même
fascinant de ne pouvoir pas parler aussi
longtemps qu'on le voudrait de l'europe
qui vous en conviendrez a quand même
plus d'incidence sur le
parler que jamais non non ne faites pas
ce procès parce qu'il est tout à fait à
chaque fois que j'ai vu on parle du
maillot de bain à au grenoble ça me va
très bien je réponds toujours pareil
néant les chances révélation c'est le
symbole est en fondant à des femmes est
ce que la question du féminisme à
laquelle à laquelle vous êtes très
attaché n'est pas un peu interrogé par
cette question du burkina voilà le
défenseur des droits ne dit pas
autrement il dit c'est une question
intérieure fichier mens sardou de
sécurité alors le règlement intérieur se
prononcer pour le reste les femmes sont
libres non
c'est pourtant la non réponse
en tout cas c'est pas la conviction
d'autres élus de gauche entre les cas
merci bonjour vincent on a vous aurait
tenté merci à vous bonne soirée et on va
commencer donc je vous les présente vous
les connaissez moi j'ai bouché steve
jours d'un message et on va commencer
par ben tiens à yannick jadot on en a
parlé oui oui vous avez parlé de
delphine batho vous avez dit qu'elle
était partante pour cet accord mais on
est rare qu'ils étaient en train de
voter moi je ne veux pas présenter des
débats internes à chaque organe des
scientistes bon en tout cas vous
l'accord il est conclu une très longue
vue la réaction dit yannick jadot il
approuve cet accord ou pas oui on en a
discuté hier quand est-ce que je les lui
dimanche chez mais je sais plus quel
jour
avant la manifestation du 1er mai j'ai
eu au téléphone justement pour discuter
un peu des derniers ajustements parce
que nous savions que nous allions vers
l'accord est donc lui évidemment
qu'est-ce qui vous êtes inscrit dans
cette coalition d'ailleurs comment dire
on a obtenu un vote de notre parlement
interne je veux pas rentrer dans le
détail mais on a obtenu 89 % parmi
lesquels évidemment des soutiens de no
kill dans ses 89 ans on n'avait pas le
droit de vote parce que c'est pas comme
ça qu'on fonctionne elle approuve mais
il soutient cette coalition il alors
historique accord exceptionnel c'est ce
qu'on entend reprendre car et lui en
fait il ne dit pas publiquement alors
que c'est à l'om une grande première
yannick jadot
sort de la campagne présidentielle et il
prend le temps qui lui est nécessaire
pour sortir de la campagne
présidentielle il est par ailleurs déjà
il a déjà fait sa rentrée au parlement
européen mais dont qu'il vous a dit
qu'il allait s'exprimer publiquement
pour approuver ils d'accord mais il
l'avait déjà dit je crois que dans la
semaine après le il a donné une
interview à sud ouest ont dû me disait
qu'il était d'accord pour la coalition
mais pas derrière jean-luc mélenchon
bien sûr il allie s'agit pas de se
ranger derrière jean-luc mélenchon nous
organisons une coalition c'est bien tout
l'enjeu de cette bannière commune j'y
reviens nous voulons une majorité il
faut bien additionner les électeurs et
les électrices ces mêmes voix qui n'ont
pas pu s'additionner à la présidentielle
on l'a vu deux fois de suite 1 il a
manqué des voix pour que la gauche et
les écologistes soient qualifiés en 2017
il a manqué des voix pour que la gauche
et les écologiste ou les écologistes
soient qualifiés en 2022 donc nous
parlons d'une coalition qui puisse
agrégé à une coalition c'est un accord
de gouvernement c'est autour et avec
c'est pas derrière c'est pas derrière on
va revenir si c'est très important c'est
d'accord les personnes qui ont pu voter
yannick jadot et j'en fais partie
doivent pouvoir se dire cette coalition
ça n'est pas juste l'union populaire et
tout le monde le comprend puisqu'il
s'agit d'additionner les personnes qui
ont voté anne hidalgo et je sais qu'en
ce moment les discussions continuent
avec le parti socialiste et après cette
émission je les rejoins nous espérons
finaliser un accord s'étant vu yannick
jadot il souhaite des législatives alors
yannick jadot je peux vous le dire il a
annoncé il ne sera pas candidat aux
législatives il est député européen et
je vous avoue que en vrai on est très
content de son travail l'appareil et
socialistes vous parlez des communistes
vous parlez moins des trotskistes et du
npa vous négociez en ce moment même avec
le hunter c'est beaucoup moins avancés
voilà je vais pas historique parce que
là pour le coup c'est vraiment ce serait
vraiment historique je vais pas c'est
sûr que moi pour le coup j'ai plus
échangée avec fabien roussel et olivier
faur
notamment sur tous les aspects
programmatiques et 7 l'importance
vraiment de cette coalition pour
additionner les échographies enjeux
communs avec le npa j'ai pas eu cet
échange encore avec le npa je vais être
très franc venez sur moi pour moi
l'accord il est déjà exceptionnel si
nous parvenons à organiser à 4 c'est à
dire l'union populaire de jean luc
mélenchon
les europe ecologie les verts ou les
écologistes que j'ai l'honneur de
représenter le parti socialiste avec
fort le parti communiste a une image
interne n'est pas une ligne rouge pour
vous moi je peux pas faire deux lignes
rouges sur les organisations nous avons
adopté un programme extrêmement
ambitieux climat justice sociale
l'égalité femmes-hommes autonomie de la
jeunesse les combattre cette réforme
injuste des retraites le rétablissement
des services publics la biodiversité
voyez la règle d'or climatique lisf
climat voilà le titre
super la création de centaines de
milliers de passagers dans le détail je
terminerais toutes les forces mais rend
tout et j'appelle les différentes forces
qui pourraient se retrouver dans se
voyait que l'idée c'est pas juste un
accord électoral on projette un espoir
voilà nous disons le 12 et 19 juin
regardez pas l'éthylène majorité
possible vous vous retrouvez dans cette
ambition
ne pas subir cinq ans d'inaction
climatique et le cas si
l'accord si l'accord il en demeure à
vous et la france insoumise et que ça ne
fonctionne pas avec le parti socialiste
le pcf le npa est ce qu'il est toujours
valable est-ce que vous irez tout seul
avec elle à la france insoumise ou
est-ce qu'il est caduque pour vous
concevez comme un ensemble moi c'est une
coalition et nous disons et d'ailleurs
c'est le communiqué commun que nous
avons signé avec la france un semis
d'hier qui dit pour être efficace
évidemment que nous voulons nous donner
tous les moyens tous les moyens pour que
les autres forces puissent se retrouver
dans cette jungle exemple si vous n'y
arrivez pas parce que vous restez dans
l'accord ou est-ce que l'accord est
caduc d'accord il est valable
nous saurons si par malheur ça se
présente mais c'est moi je veux quand
j'ai quitté mon chien moi quand j'ai
quitté la table des discussions pour
venir à cette émission parce que c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé tout
l'après-midi
les insoumis et les socialistes quand
j'ai quitté la table n'y a pas de raison
que ça ne puisse passer à table
justement vous avez négocié commun de
circonscription pour paris où là
oui parce que donc les écologie sont
circonscription non mais c'est parce que
je crois dans 100 centaines alors
centaines à paris il y aura donc
sans ordre précis la troisième qui donc
le 17ème et 18ème arrondissements la
cinquième les 3e et 10e arrondissements
qui la 8e les
12e arrondissement 10 ans disons les
choses comme ça et la neuvième pour le
13ème arrondissement ces 44
circonscriptions qui sont très
importantes pour nous et qui permettent
aussi de couvrir des villas à paris je
suis moi même candidat j'ai été investis
et
nous avons finalisé cet accord sur les
3e et 10e arrondissements autour de la
place de république à paris et sandrine
rousseau elle est dans quelle
circonscription sandrine rousseau aller
sur la 9e circonscription xiiie
arrondissement
les deux autres s'étant en voie de
finalisation interne c'est à dire qu'on
a eu un accord sur le périmètre
la bannière commune le programme
cette délimitation des circonscriptions
et ensuite nous allons investir
option il y en a combien de gagnable eh
ben ça dépend si les électeurs le décide
son nom
mais vous avez déjà dit oui le
c'est d'assurer un groupe et c'est pas
sur la chaîne parlementaire que je vais
dire qu'un groupe à l'assemblée s'était
15 ans il y en avait pas dans le mandat
précédent on a mesuré à quel point il
manquait un groupe écolo veut aller
beaucoup plus loin
aujourd'hui tout est ouvert si nous nous
rassemblons
est que nous répondrons moi je ressens
vraiment l'immense attente qui pèsent
sur ce début de rassemblement que nous
avons impulsé
il veut plus l'union que l'écologie
non je pourrais pas vous laisser dire ça
parce que les attentes c'est fascinant
d'ailleurs les attentes en matière de
climat et d'environnement ont jamais été
aussi haute même au coeur de la crise
vers les sciences de la crise sociale se
rend compte à quel point la tente et on
mesure à quel point les promesses de
emmanuel macron ne sont pas suivies
d'effet et que ça génère évidemment une
frustration même une anxiété dans la
genèse qui est extrêmement prégnante
nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps pour
répondre à l'enjeu climatique c'est
maintenant qu'il faut pour ça que vous
voulez poser pour les 50 dans votre
accord et la coalition que vous
souhaitez vous dit ce n'est pas derrière
jean-luc mélenchon si on prend la
question des retraites jean luc
mélenchon et l'accord que vous avez
trouvé c'est sur une retraite à 60 ans
yannick jadot lui dans son programme
présidentiel il proposait 62 ans était
il ya encore quinze jours trois semaines
ça veut dire quoi que c'est un reniement
par rapport au programme des écologistes
à la présidentielle a lu tout non nous
disions 62 ans qui peut le plus que le
mans a minima nous voulons nous opposer
à la réforme des retraites à 65 ans
parfaitement juste même pas nécessaire
nous dit le conseil d'orientation des
retraites oui mais soit nécessaire en
revanche c'est nécessaire et donc
équilibrer leurs régimes dans le
problème sorcières c'était 62 ans avec
un pour nous c'est extrêmement important
un enjeu majeur sur la pénibilité parce
que c'est pas vous faire offense mais
votre travail est le mien et et des fois
moins pénible que celui qui consiste à
porter des charges lourdes où les
ménages donc c'est pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt et sur
les autres ce sera 62 donc nous avons
travaillé nous avons réussi à travailler
et à converger avec la france insoumise
mais en fait également avec le parti
socialiste et ça c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour dire 60 ans est prise en
compte de la pénibilité il se sentant
pour tout le monde et donc nous des
marathons pour nous développerons ses
aspects moins que l'âge légal dans votre
programme
soit environ donc vous reculez pas vous
avancez l'âge légal à la retraite vous
passer de 62 ça s'équilibre plus et bien
justement la france insoumise nous a
présenté un chiffrage qui tient la route
et donc on le présentera on est encore
en train d'analyser le palm présenté au
conseil d'orientation des retraites mais
en fait pas si vous avez eu un petit peu
ce qu'a dit le conseil d'orientation des
retraites c'est qu'il disait en gros
dans 15 ans et équilibrée mais savait
avant la pause non à 60 ans c'était non
monsieur non non c'était équilibré grâce
à leur forme
regardez regardez nous regarde et vous
pouvez pas dire le contraire excusez moi
c'était l'équilibré grâce à la réforme
et c'est équilibré également grâce à la
reprise qui était beaucoup plus forte
que prévu que prévu en 2021 et donc
s'ils n'ont peut-être pas 15 ans mais
ses douze donc on attend les chercheurs
qui fascine on a brillé ce qui est
fascinant à regarder
vous me faites la critique et c'est
votre rôle simplement aujourd'hui on a
un président qui a annoncé 65 ans
semblent aucunement le justifier et vous
contestez mais c'est vous me dites 60
ans et nous et nous nous débattons
moyens anciens henry juillet pas
nécessaire d'aller à 65 ans et servir
c'est que vous me dites je vous dis 60
ans et vous
sa réforme je vous ai pas encore par
ailleurs 58% des français l'ont élu
quand ça vous sinon effectivement sauna
excusez moi alors deux choses moi j'ai
voté emmanuel macron c'est certainement
pas pour ce projet c'était pour battre
marine le pen et je crois qu'on est
plutôt nombreux dans ce cas et je m'en
réjouis c'était en fait mon seul sujet
dans l'entre-deux-tours faire battre
marine le pen mais très important quand
ils ont voulu faire passer la réforme
des retraites à 65 ans déjà juste avant
mars 2020 et juste avant le coup vide et
si vous souvenez des gens par 49 3 c'est
à dire en gros en allant contre le
parlement
il n'avait pas proposé de chiffrage
c'est à dire que là vous contestez mais
mes arguments et c'est heureux et c'est
le rôle des journalistes mais quand ils
ont proposé une réforme des retraites à
65 ans ils n'ont pas proposé de chapeau
monsieur on va avancer mais je le vois
comme si
à 60 ans pour tous ça veut dire quoi
qu'on aura une retraite à taux plein à
60 ans c'est pas possible nous
présenterons les modalités et le
chiffrage en temps voulu une fois que
vous avez compris en moyenne à 63 ans et
demi pour avoir une retraite à taux
plein donc en fait développement on
pourra partir à 60 ans mais la plupart
des gens partiront après ce méme alors
livré ce sera comme ça en dit long les
la réalité des faits c'est à dire qu'en
fait les gens partent déjà à 62 ou 63
mais la moitié sont hors travail parce
qu'ils sont cassés parce qu'ils sont
abîmés parce qu'ils sont malades ou
parce qu'ils sont au chômage parce
qu'ils n'ont pas une retraite à taux
plein et si vous retarder le départ
comme le prévoit ce gouvernement était
en fait vous les laisser plus longtemps
au chômage en maladie ou cassés et donc
en fait c'est une retraite c'est qui
part d'un point de vue vraiment
parfaitement idéologique la chimère qui
voudrait qu'on travaille plus longtemps
parce qu'on vit plus longtemps nous
disons on vit plus longtemps parce qu'on
travaille dans des meilleures conditions
et donc nous contestons leur approche
voilà elle n'est ni nécessaire ni juste
ference de vie l'espérance de vie des
personnes travaillent dans des métiers
les plus pénibles elle est inférieure de
8 à 10 ans des personnes qui ont la
chance d'avoir des métiers moins pénible
et donc c'est pour ça que nous nous
bataillons pour la prise en compte de la
pénibilité par pour tous la retraite à
ce sens c'est pour ça que nous disons
que cette réforme des retraites elle est
parfaitement injuste et à l'étranger
stein travail partons partageant le
travail la réduction du temps de travail
l'égalité femmes-hommes c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ce pas vous je vais
l'apprendre mesdames pardon
la réforme l'inégalité salariale
évidemment se traduit par des inégalités
de pensions puisque moins de revenus
pour les femmes
cette inégalité il faut la combattre ça
ne passe pas que par la réforme des
retraites il ya la réduction du temps de
travail l'égalité femmes-hommes
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
voilà tout ce qu'il m'a tant
apporté avec une majorité on va parler
de la réforme des institutions la 6ème
république elle figure dans l'accord que
vous avez signé avec les insoumis cette
réforme cette instauration de la sixième
république vous allez là présentée par
référendum aux français alors moi je ne
vais pas dévoiler tous les aspects c'est
le 6ème république c'est non papa ou sur
le lien quelque chose à payer mais pas
aujourd'hui le temps de la campagne
démarre seulement nous aurons j'espère
une convention d'investiture le 7 mai ce
samedi qui pourra lancer la campagne
nous portons la 6ème république nous les
écologistes depuis au moins aussi
longtemps que la france ainsi mise et
c'est pour ça que ça n'a pas été
compliqué de se rejoindre nous
combattons le présidentialisme le fait
que comme aujourd'hui le président
décide de tout tout seul pour tout le
monde quand même on sait même plus il ya
un conseil des ministres ils ont inventé
un conseil de défense qui n'est prévu
dans aucun texte sanitaire est
parfaitement choisi à la main du
président et qui demande au président et
au parlement de choisir vraiment vous
réformer cette vème république
proportionnelle intégrale oui la
proportionnelle intégrale par un terme
et notamment la parité c'est important
la parité vous avez comme ça une parité
de résultats puisque pour établir des
listes il vous faut hommes femmes hommes
femmes à la fin vous avez autant de
femmes que d'hommes vous avez peut-être
gouvernement de stabilité plus de
pouvoir au parlement
aujourd'hui vous savez et encore une
fois je m'en veux de lire ici c'est le
gouvernement qui
dispose de
l'agenda parlementaire est en partie
devant 10% des bois racisme oui personne
n'est dupe 90% des lois sont issus en
fait de projet de loi c'est à dire du
gouvernement et les dix autres sont en
fait souvent des projets de loi que en
fait on fait passer par des propositions
doit forcément moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est de savoir comment vous aboutissez
cette 6ème république ben alors pour la
proportionnelle c'est juste une loi
comme vous le savez et ensuite il ya
tous les aspects de référendum et y en
aura donc il y aura un référendum est
gelée présent et je les présenterai
quand mes yeux référendum car seul le
président peut proposer aux gens
présents et nous le présenterons nous
présenterons ces éléments invoqués
manuel macron proposera aux français une
réforme de la sagam à nous présenter
jean-luc mélenchon mais sur proposition
d'une assemblée dont évidemment le
premier groupe serait celui des insoumis
oui par exemple vous y croyez encore
enfin vous pensez que tu m'apportes et
c'est très flou pour vous quand vous
serez aux manettes mais a fait ce qui
est fascinant c'est que le président de
la république sortant ou le nouveau
candidat et réinvestit bientôt samedi
n'a cessé de dire qu'il voulait inventer
vous savez une nouvelle gouvernance
alors c'est jupiter il est directement
parti le soir même à la lanterne pour se
reposer et décider de tout on sait même
plus si un premier ministre
mais il parle quand même en tout cas
beaucoup de nouvelles gouvernances
d'horizontalité de respect des corps
intermédiaires nous le ferons
même si les juristes disent que c'est
pas constitutionnel de faire passer ce
genre de référendum eh bien nous verrons
parce que sur la proportionnelle je vous
le redis c'est cannoise sur le fait de
modifier le modifier et de donner plus
de poids au parlement pour fixer
l'agenda évidemment ça dépend d'un
règlement intérieur qui est visé par le
conseil constitutionnel évidemment ça
peut dépendre de règles ça peut aussi
dépendre de la coutume si le ministre
des relations avec le parlement dit mais
écoutez allez-y et bien en fait on
organise la chose je désobéis il me
semble pas il me semble pas que par
exemple il ya une règle qui fixe la
parité dans un gouvernement si demain un
gouvernement venais à ne plus être
paritaires tout le monde serait choqué
forte heureusement nous voyez la
tradition la mise en oeuvre dans cette
vème république
de nouvelles règles par exemple autre
exemple nous voulons envoyer par le
pouvoir d'achat alors je termine nous
voulons l'indépendance de la justice
vous me direz
comme tout le monde oui sauf que nous
voulons vraiment et vous me direz
réforme constitutionnelle sauf que si le
garde des sceaux où la garde des sceaux
dans prochain gouvernement dit ok je
m'engage à suivre les avis du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature nous
n'avons pas fait la réforme
constitutionnelle mais nous avons adopté
l'indépendance de la justice puisque la
promotion la carrière des juges n'est
plus dépendante de l'exécutif
voilà une manière très concrète de
répondre à toutes les accusations de la
convention européenne des droits l'homme
sur le fait que la justice
administrative n'est pas indépendant
dans ce pays reste très concret ça peut
se faire effectivement comme vous avez
raison sur les aspects constitutionnels
et emmanuel macron ont échoué à réformer
la constitution je suis papa quand il y
avait ceux qui l'ont promis et ils ne
m'ont pas fait parce que le sénat parce
qu'ils sont passés par là mais ils n'ont
pas pour autant et que le sénat a bloqué
mais ils n'ont pas pour autant établi
cette tradition et j'ai bien vu que le
garde des sceaux dupond moretti avait
rayé de la promotion un juge ensemble
que c'était le juge tournaire parce
qu'il avait eu le toupet de mettre en
échec la sarre comme
s'égare pas la
justice et un gouvernement issu d'une
majorité plurielle pourrait mettre en
oeuvre en dix ans alors qu'ils n'ont pas
le 10 mx est entendue sur cet accord de
gouvernement avec jean luc mélenchon sur
un smic à 1400 euros c'est bien cela
yannick jadot proposait 1500 euros
est-ce que vous avez révisé à la baisse
vos ambitions sociales pour les français
commencent par 1400 euros évidemment
donc ça veut dire quoi qu'à la fin du
quinquennat on sera à 1500 euros vous
comprenez que la prise en compte des
engagements sur les retraites se traduit
par des engagements sur les salaires
nous avons
adopté le meilleur ou en tout cas d'aidé
des convergences très forte des
programmes issus du programme de yannick
jadot ou du programme de jean luc
mélenchon donc
l'ambition de 10 mais tout cas on va
commencer par 1400 euros nuit vous
commencez par un 1400 euros mais par
exemple on s'engage aussi sur un monde
autre aspect qui compense et qui bien
sûr est celui de la douche n'a quand
même toujours l'impression que vous
ligne et sur le programme de jean luc
mélenchon que ce soit sur les retraites
que ce soit sur la 6ème république que
ce soit là sur le smic c'est toujours
derrière le programme de jean luc vous
avez obtenu comme concept alors les
moins 65 % d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre pour nous c'est absolument
cruciale c'est peut être mélenchon le
souhaite également donc dans ce cas là
tant mieux mais dans ce cas là pour nous
ça veut dire ça conditionne l'ensemble
des politiques publiques menées vraie
nouveauté permet pas fait bouger
finalement le projet commun la 'règle
d'or' climatique le fait de conditionner
toutes les aides toutes les aides au
respect des accords de paris ou à la
continue de conditionnalité sociale ça
n'est pas rien vous savez que dans ce
pays où il ya beaucoup de bêtes public
ou de de commandes publiques aux
alentours de 1% du pib inquiète et su en
fait de l'activité de l'état des
collectivités territoriales des villes
la commande publique quand elle est
conditionnée mais alain pouvoir
d'entraînement exception c'est ce que
voulait dire le
programme
la bobine jean luc mélenchon sur sur les
bulletins etc si c'est ça que vous
voulez entendre entende et le je vous
dis que nous avons une bannière commune
que nous avons une coalition que les
écologistes en sont un des moteurs que
bien sûr issue de la présidentielle les
insoumis jean luc mélenchon et ont un
rôle important ainsi
fort et que nous serons ensemble
passé n'est pas derrière c'est au tour
avec souffrez que ça soit une coalition
et qu'effectivement nous voulons
additionner les électorats vous pouvez
pas nous reprocher d'avoir tiré les
leçons de la présidentielle
si jean-luc ministre tiendra couacs au
ministère vous en avez parlé pendant une
coalition où un gouvernement issu de
cette coalition vous souhaitez quoi mais
on n'est pas du tout rentrer là dedans
nous c'est ya six semaines de campagne
donc je ne croyais pas si vous y croyez
vous avez envisagé la suite quand même
enfin comment dire c'est comme quand
vous me parlez de circonscriptions
gagnables moi je connais qu'une seule
circonscription gagnable c'est là où les
électeurs et les électrices ils ont
décidé oui donc les circassiens
présidentielle ou moins faveur non mais
attendez enfin envisager un petit peu
certaines je suis comprends mais enfin
il me semble peut-être je me trompe que
vous voyez ces discussions comme et que
je te donne 6 et que tu connaissais g de
gouves c'est pas ça du tout et quelque
chose mais nous avons passé un temps
important
les discussions sur le roc madame away
we sur le fait que le cadre du tcg ne
nous convenait pas
il a expliqué ses positions et vous vous
y êtes rallier c'est ce qu'il a dit
sexuellement ce matin sur france inter
nous nous avons expliqué ce que nous
voulons faire en guise de négociations
et finalement europe ecologie les verts
ça vous agrée moi ça ne me dérangera pas
nous avons fait ce que nous voulons
faire et nous nous sommes rendu compte
que nous avions des convergences
incroyable quelles sont les lois
defferre au niveau international nous
avions
madame il y avait une présidentielle là
vous savez que l'international nom d'une
présidentielle est important et sur ces
sujets les désaccords demeurent quelles
sont les lois vous allez à projets les
institutions aux parents avec la faveur
des législatives nous pouvons mettre en
oeuvre une coalition pluriel voilà et
alors qu'on se dit strictement faire
vous allez quand vous serez au aux
manettes quelles sont les lois vous à
les abroger est ce que la loi
anti-casseurs vous allez l'abroger par
exemple la loi anti-casseurs plume 2019
ce qui permet d'encadrer les
manifestations et qui est souvent décrit
à gauche alors je suis pas moi à ce
niveau 2 de précisions alors plus
généralement quelles sont les lois que
vous voulez abrogé qu'on vous serez aux
manettes mais je les présenterai la
liste et dont il ya des lois que nous
voulons mettre en oeuvre il ya le droit
au logement en particulier l'égalité
salariale il ya la garantie de tonneaux
me de la jeunesse il ya effectivement la
réforme de l'assurance chômage sur
laquelle nous voulons revenir il ya les
différentes ordonnances elle comme riz
et autres
nous allons produire un programme sur
lequel nous sommes encore en train de
travailler de plusieurs centaines de
mesures voilà ce sera un programme
complet du droit du travail droit du
logement droits de la nature à présenter
quand quand est ce qu'on aura un
programme très dit non du mois de mai
donc ya pas une date en particulier pas
encore laissé la campagne se déroule et
je comprends évidemment votre attente je
la partage mais simplement nous sommes
aussi en train de élargir cette
coalition moi je m'en réjouis je
retournerai après cette émission
discuter avec les socialistes les
communistes et donc
l'art écologique et sociale et
officialisation de 7,2 cette grande
coalition
pourrait avoir lieu
très heureux qu'on me pose autant de
questions sur le programme alors que
cette coalition n'a pas encore vu
officiel
qui fait moins de 5% à présidentielle du
coup vous n'êtes pas remboursé de vos
frais de campagne vous avez lancé un
appel aux dons c est récoltée je crois
deux millions un peu plus de 2 millions
d'euros 2,2 millions d'euros il vous
manque un million d'ici quinze jours
c'est ça et vous espérez les avoir et
oui on se mobilise pour pour les obtenir
c'est sûr que pour nous faire moins de 5
% c'est un enjeu d'abord majeur
politiquement évidemment mais aussi
financier à une ardoise de 5 millions
d'euros et vous l'avez dit 3 millions
d'euros à trouver avant les échéances de
mi mai plus de deux millions d'euros
récoltés sur soutenir l'écologie point
fr plus de 40000 dont des dons ce avec
le plafond est à 7500 euros nous avons
reçu de dons à 7500 euros c'est la
première fois notre histoire et une
multitude de dons à 3 euros parce qu'en
fait quand on fait le calcul si chaque
électeurs électrices de yannick jadot
donne 3 euros nous sommes
avec les insoumis par exemple est ce qui
pourrait vous aider à faire la jointure
si jamais il vous manque ce million
d'euros
et puis vous pourriez les randonnées 17
ça ne concerne que qu'europe écologie
les verts moi je me réjouis si vous
voulez
juste de donateurs et donatrices que
d'adhérents est à dire
ça c'est un fait politique en fait il ya
un attachement je donnerai pas son nom
mais il ya une parlementaire modem qui a
donné je l'aï immédiatement remerciés à
miser voilà nous avons besoin d'un parti
écologiste solide dans le pays elles
gardent pas qu'elle vote avec nous tout
le temps je dirais pas que nous avons
les mêmes d'asie en vrai nous ne sommes
pas vraiment rencontré mais elle dit
c'est important que dans cette
démocratie dans cette république et avec
la charge des accords de paris un parti
écologiste puisse refleurir c'est un
joli député modem qui vous un
parlementaire je veux pas voilà non mais
je sais que vous allez retrouver si vous
faite élire
qui a donné je l'en remercie merci
beaucoup en tout cas brigitte et
six-fours ce débat très animé juste un
instant une question y frère va bien
nous rejoindre vous êtes favorable à ce
que les états unis livre massivement les
armes à l'ukraine oui oui
parce qu'il n'ya pas le mot du tout le
cren dans l'accord que vous avez qu'on
la dise soumises donc effectivement on
est un peu troublé c'est un sujet vous
n'avez pas abordés vous restez chacun
sur vos dents mais laissez les aspects
internationale on l'a dit les aspects
qui relève de l'international c'est
qu'on en pense dans cette vème
république une sorte de terrain réservé
au président de la république moi j'ai
noté les évolutions puisque vous y venez
de jean luc mélenchon les des récentes
déclarations sur les crimes perpétrés
par l'armée russe vous parliez de
l'interview de manuel bompard qui
évoquait les livraisons d'armes et
compris lourde à l'ukraine évidemment
nous avons appelé immédiatement à
soutenir la résistance aucune ambiguïté
là dessus on veut changer le passé vous
reconnaissez bonsoir bonsoir soir alors
je vous ai écouté tout à fait
attentivement et je me disais au fil de
la conversation que finalement c'est un
aveu d'échec votre accord là ça veut
dire que vous êtes vous vous soumettez
aux insoumis d'une certaine façon
sur les graines toutes les mesures qui
ont été détaillées par elisabeth et et
mes deux confrères et consoeurs c'est
vous êtes en situation d'être soumis et
bien à la france un assouplissement
hormis ce mauvais jeu de mots est-ce
qu'on peut rentrer dans le détail oui
bon nous voulons une majorité à
l'assemblée je crois qu'elle est
possible vous êtes prêts à tout pour
avoir une majorité certainement pas
qu'est-ce que nous avons rogné par
exemple qu'est-ce que nous avons rogner
de nos ambitions ou qu'est-ce que nous
avons renier de nos convictions je vous
mets au défi sur l'europe l'islamo
gauchisme - vous soyez un peu
islamologie l'atripla dites moi dis pas
parce que sur l'europe j'ai écrit ce
livre en 2018 2019 ouais qu'a t-il
changé depuis si ce n'est que toutes les
règles osterrieth air ont volé en éclats
je le disais et je vais me permettre de
le redire nous avons une ambition pour
l'europe qui dépasse le cadre actuel
aujourd'hui faire de la politique dans
les traités dans le cadre c'est
compliqué il se trouve que tout est à
voler en éclats qui veut que ça revienne
au statu quo pas nous à ce que je
constate si vous mettez en doute projet
mettez-vous depuis qu'on a qu'on va
aller plus loin s'il vous plaît vous
mettez en doute mon attachement au
projet européen oui ou non mais je le
mets si je le mets en doute un petit peu
parce que aujourd'hui vous êtes en train
de le renier mais je vous défends un
signe on sait pas n'est pas vrai au
contraire au contraire bah vous n'allez
pas dire le contraire je rencontre et
non en exemple le pas dire ça parce que
ça serait malhonnête projet européen
vais pas me dire que c'est le contraire
puisque cosy vous êtes un européen
congrès ce que l'on se connaît avec un
livre avec un livre qui vous a quand
même que vous avez écrit avec vos tripes
justement pour les obéissons montrer
l'europe montré mais jean-luc mélenchon
s'est absolument pas ça qui vous en avez
discuté faisait sortir de l'europe et
bien sûr car ces exemples je prends la
campagne des européennes nous emporte et
j'en suis fier l'idée d'un nouveau
traité européen
parce que disons le les traités issus de
57 à mende et maastricht et 97 se
concentre sur on va dire la concurrence
et c'est vrai souvent la privatisation
des marchés publics nous disons il faut
un nouveau traité pour qu'enfin on
prenne en compte les limites planétaires
c'était une proposition de marie
toussaint dans la campagne des
européennes
voilà ce que nous voulons faire corps
voilà ce que vous voulez dire que ça ça
n'est pas une ambition une chose c'est
pas une ambition pour l'europe il ya une
chose qui me prend je peux continuer oui
mais si vous mettez moi savez
vous avez répondu je suis européen vous
avez fédéral alors je vais l'aimer sans
coup je vous réponds je vais aller plus
loin et regarder on
rien débat qui dit à droite et bien il
ya une digue entre la république entre
pardon les républicains et le corps
nationaliste représentée par madame le
pen y avait pas ce qu'est le monsieur
emmanuel a beaucoup qui voyait bien on
est d'accord noir que dans la primaire
des droites les deux tchèques a sauté
des deux tiers des députés ne veulent
surtout pas faire cause commune avec les
nationalistes monsieur ce nom mais pour
moi ce que je trouve incroyable c'est
que dans ce pays vous avez une extrême
gauche quand vous avez une extrême
droite et que des pays des partis
sociaux démocrates parti socialiste
parti écologiste le parti radical de
gauche qui lui dit niet on ne veut pas
aller dans cet accord en question parce
qu'on ne partage pas du tout les mêmes
valeurs comment vous expliquez que cette
digue eh bien on en fait peu de cas
excusez moi vous pouvez pas mettre sur
le même plan alors ça c'est le
hockey de venise et non
la primaire de droite si vous vous
souvenez et c'est intéressant vous
parliez d'europe parce que moi j'ai
entendu les candidats l'émoi de la
gauche non non non les candidats comme
barnier comme valérie pécresse
comme eric ciotti envoyer valdinguer
tout l'acquis communautaire
alors il fallait sortir ah bah non mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas vrai
ils ont pris un engagement de se
présenter moi j'ai entendu leur
étiquette sans faire un liant aux
législatives sauf les cas d'ahmed
reviendrai là elle souffre et que je
vous répondre mais que je puisse vous
objecter que moi j'ai entendu dans la
primaire de droite des idées d'extrême
droite bon
million actuellement il n'ya pas d'union
à gauche eag rocher avec les écologistes
nous organisons une coalition alors on
va les petits portent sur le
rétablissement des services publics qui
porte sur l'application des accords de
paris qui porte sur la rénovation
thermique vous pouvez placer l'islamo
gauchisme ça veut rien dire en fait
c'est parce que je vais vous en parler
maintenant a très bien vu un bio vous
êtes vous êtes juriste vous êtes avocat
comment vous pouvez accepter qui hier et
ce matin des députés et des élus de la
france insoumise après les désordres
dans la rue les violences qui a eu avec
des d'aider des gens qui s'en sont pris
aux pompiers absolument scandaleux et
j'ai vu ces images wii vous pouvez
écraser avec des gens qui condamne le
préfet de police de paris mais qui ne
disent rien des casseurs je comprends
jeu c'est marrant parce que là pour le
prouver si je vais je vais vous répondre
mais j'ai quand même l'impression des
fois que j'ai avec 1
des fois c'est un journaliste des fois
vous êtes quasiment politique abbassi
excusez-moi garde
à vrai dire dès hier soir quand j'ai vu
ces images de cette femme qui s'en prend
un pompier moi je condamne toutes les
violences d'où qu'elles viennent en
particulier quand elles concernent des
personnes qui mettent
leur vie au service du bien public c'est
les policiers et évidemment les pompiers
quand j'ai vu cette agression c'est
vraiment c'est honteux voilà et
effectivement les casseurs de plus en
plus dans les manifestations
fait qu'en fait on ne parle plus de la
marche ou la la fête des travailleuses
et de travailleurs c'est de ces idioties
ces casseurs décérébrés font extrêmement
de tort ils s'en prennent aux biens
publics s'en prennent aux personnes il
m'a regardée au préfet de police de
paris comme monsieur bompard monsieur je
trouve qu'effectivement nous avons un
problème de maintien de l'ordre alors
pourquoi est-ce que ça vous est ce que
ça vous surprend est-ce que vous
condamnez c'est ce que ça vous surprend
que je dise qu'il ya un problème de
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre puisque
en angleterre ou en allemagne il est
possible de manifester alors que c'est
plus difficile en france convenait
convenez que le premier mais un peu
traditionnelle que moi j'ai pu connaître
que les jeunes générations peut-être ne
connaissent plus et que vous sans vous
faire offense vous avez connu oui le 1er
mai où vous pouvez manifester en famille
sereinement depuis 2016 c'est devenu
très compliqué il ya une difficulté du
maintien de l'ordre évidemment il ya
bien sûr la première et entière des
premières à temps des premières et
entière responsabilité de ces casseurs
mais il ya un sujet du maintien de
l'ordre lui fait d'accord mais alors
pourquoi vous est d'ailleurs contestée
quoi vous ne vous nous ne le dit pas et
pourquoi vous ne vous décelez izarry pas
des propos de la france à soumah est
sûre les propos violents qu'on ne m'avez
pas écouté ce matin c'est certainement
pour ça et je ne vous en veux pas et
c'est moi qui ai commencé par bien sûr
dénoncer les violences et je le redis
d'où qu'elles viennent donc la question
jean luc mélenchon nuit conduit par
commentateurs des tweets malaisie
ras-le-bol et il disait ras-le-bol
des casseurs bon ben si vous les jeux
comme tous les tweets on prendra plus de
temps ce n'est pas mon job
je conduis une coalition j'ai l'honneur
de conduire les écologistes dans une
coalition de lutte tous en ont contribué
à mettre sur pied un programme ambitieux
pour le pays sur les salaires sur le
climat sur l'égalité voilà l'enjeu mais
compte tenu de tout ça est ce que vous
êtes sûr que votre base qui a voté
certes tout le monde est d'accord j'ai
le gel non par exemple de marine
chaillou argenteuil qui a dit non moi
cet accord ça me convient pas du tout
elle devait être candidate aux
législatives dans cette circonscription
du val d'oise si je ne m'abuse et
finalement elle se retire elle dit non
moi je dans ces conditions je ne veux
pas activé avec par france insoumise
avec laquelle je ne partage pas les
idées même si des jeux là pour le coup
je sais pas qui c'est donc ça m'embête
parce que évidemment vous trouvez
quelqu'un toujours mais je ne sais pas
qui c'est et ici elle était
effectivement désignée candidate sur une
circonscription qui ne revient pas dans
l'accord je peux comprendre qu'elle en
soit un peu frustré gap à une partie de
votre électorat
est ce que vous aviez déjà entendu
parler de cette personne avant mais je
le sais parce que je travaille dur est
d'accord c'est mon métier d'aller voir
ok c'est pas moi je peux vous trouvez
aussi des gens qui m'ont dit oui est-ce
que ça je la verrai quand pas tous les
jours cette dame vraiment monsieur
traire elles sont vraiment remettront en
cause la qualité de votre travail
si je vous trouve de personnes qui
disent qu elles sont contentes vous
allez dire que ça fait deux contre un
c'est pas sérieux et en l'occurrence
celle du figaro puisque c'est la base
d'une enquête est-ce que c'est très
sérieux est-ce que c'est très sérieux la
grisaille on discute c'est très sérieux
de prendre appui sur une personne
c'est très sérieux quand vous avez un
article dans un journal qui va paraître
demain ou
homicide sur des élus alors voilà europe
ecologie les verts qui disent nous ne
voulons pas participer à cet accord est
donc dans ces conditions et bien on on
ne se présentera pas sous la bannière
surtout si cet investissement
surtout si ça attendez mais il refusa
mais s'ils sont investis s'ils sont pas
investis vous comprenez attendez
attendez non mais vraiment je vous
réponds de points bah écoutez
on n'a jamais parlé de cette personne
nous demander de répondre il la connaît
pas elle est certainement alors
parfaitement
s'il vous plaît si elle est écologiste
elle est super maintenant la réalité et
les faits sur lequel nous pouvons
prendre appui c'est un mandat de 95 % de
mon conseil fédéral et ça ça c'est pas
j'ai rencontré quelqu'un c'est le
parlement s'est dit d'accord parlement
95% vous savez des fois nous on vote la
démocratie interne on y croit ça vaut
beaucoup plus excuser moi que tous les
petits micros trottoirs que vous avez pu
faire d'accord pour les journalistes
mais est ce que vous n'avez pas peur
avec cet accord là qu'une partie de
l'électorat j'entends la partie de
l'électorat
qui voyait d'un bon oeil monsieur
jeannot d'ailleurs qui lui convenait
même si le score a pas été
extraordinaire la présidentielle il ya
se déporte vers monsieur enfin vers la
majorité présidentielle actuelle
écoutez la difficulté c'est que le
président promet beaucoup et déçoit tout
le temps et si on est écologiste on ne
peut pas être satisfait du mandat qui
s'est écoulé et si on est écologiste est
un tout petit peu charpenté on ne peut
pas s'attendre à ce que ça s'améliore
toutes les promesses n'engagent que ceux
qui les croient mais simplement on a
déjà payé pour voir que ces promesses
c'était du vent on a déjà vu le grand
débat à l'issue des villes et jaune
500000 contribution sur l'environnement
est finalement un débat sur
l'immigration on a déjà vu
convention citoyenne pour le climat cent
quarante neuf propositions installé par
le président lui-même qui voulait
reprendre sans filtre et qui les jette à
la broyeuse nous avons déjà alors
l'interdiction de la chasse
traditionnelle est particulièrement
cruelle à la glu et le président lui
même qui a écrit aux chasseurs pour leur
dire promis dans le chaos dieu l'établi
attendait ça va vous plaire pour être
contre la jurisprudence européenne
on était en droit européen autre
question respectons l'état de droit
européen autre question l'état de droit
européen nous dit on en finit avec la
chasse traditionnelle nous le font
d'autres questions c'est la dernière
vous écoute depuis le début que vous
êtes en politique je sais votre
attachement à la lutte antinucléaire oui
vous allez avoir un partenaire bientôt
là si ça marche cette nuit qui s'appelle
fabien roussel qui représente le parti
communiste et qui dit moi je suis pour
le mix énergétique je veux du nucléaire
la sortie progressive du nucléaire
personne ne dit sortie demain la réalité
c'est que nous avons quoi 40% des
réacteurs à l'arrêt ainsi les réacteurs
sont à l'arrêt ce n'est pas de notre
fait c'est parce qu'ils sont inspectés
par l'autorité de sûreté du nucléaire
c'est pas fiable nucléaire et c'est pas
l'indépendance énergétique la véritable
indépendance énergétique et les énergies
renouvelables nous voulons nous donner
les moyens avec cette coalition d'aller
chercher le 100% énergies renouvelables
et ça passe aussi par la rénovation
thermique voilà l'enjeu matériel
électoral il en est d'accord le vote
matériel électoral il aura
bonjour vous avez hâte oui non mais
s'ils
décideront nous en déciderons vous
verrez ça ans mais je sais que vous avez
la campagne ne fait que commencer
d'ailleurs n'a pas été tout à fait
lancée rendez vous samedi le 7 merci
pour ça mais merci à vous en tout cas
julien bayou je retrouve vous êtes
fatigué vous êtes crever vous avez
presque pas dormi vous êtes venu et vous
y retourner mais on vous sent dedans un
est prêt à utiliser ce moment ratio on
se souvient aussi d'avoir été notre
invité dans un indice en public on se
retrouve bien sûr la semaine prochaine à
19h30 merci et bonne semaine bercy
[Musique]